americans are on the move this memorial
day weekend throwing aside pandemic
restrictions to get a head start on
summer airports are especially busy the
tsa has screened at least
five and a half million people since
thursday you can expect big crowds today
at many popular destinations
a drastic change from one year ago lilia
luciano
is at lax los angeles international
airport good morning lilia
good morning to you michelle many
americans are eager to break free
from covet confinement and memorial day
is proof of that with airports like this
one
seeing record numbers of flyers compared
to last year
singing don't worry
this busy boardwalk in san diego just
one of the popular tourist destinations
welcoming back crowds this memorial day
weekend
the past couple days have been crazy
sarah blair a manager at hollywood
burger in los angeles says the increase
in visitors is a welcome sign
of a busy summer ahead what has business
been like these days
um super exciting actually more than 37
million people plan to travel
50 miles or more this weekend according
to aaa
up 60 percent from last year
[Music]
at the nation's airports long overdue
reunions
it's been over a year since we've seen
them
many families like the hayes who are
visiting grandparents in arizona
flew for the first time in over a year
there are signs of recovery across the
country the largest sporting event since
the pandemic began
at indianapolis motor speedway where a
hundred and thirty five thousand fans
watched racer elio castroneves's
indy 500 win
and while rain kept many inside along
the east coast
there were crowds at boston's famed
fenway park
and the streets of d.c as well as on
beaches and water parks
real relief and celebration to be able
to be outside again and feel safe
the travel brush comes as covet cases
declined to the lowest number of new
cases in more than a year
this as over half of americans are now
partially vaccinated
it's actually getting better we see
light at the end of the tunnel so it's
quite refreshing